so I think it's safe to say that Randy's
coming with the receipts okay yeah
interesting very interesting we do see
in the trailer for the season it looks
like you're female I get emails well hi
how are you I'm good I'm inside I'm
social distancing I'm you know doing
doing the quarantine but what are you
doing to entertain yourself oh we're all
trapped inside
nothing I'm a news junkie so I am you
know glued to the news which isn't
always the best and I've been I don't
know like I have it like a ton of books
and I start them and I never finished
them so of course this is the perfect
time to do so and of course I haven't
done you're watching the news you're not
binging anything on TV no I'm not I'm
not I'm not a binge up there I don't
know everybody else is like you need to
watch Tiger King you need to you know I
mean okay I just haven't done it you'll
get around to it I think I have the time
yeah we all have the time well we have a
new season of Housewives coming our way
to fill some of that time how are you
feeling about this season I think it's
gonna be good I really think that we
have a great season you don't want to be
here then go
don't try and destroy my family
what if she's manipulating me it feels
like we gotta seize them we got like a
very good season all around well I think
that you know I think you do but I feel
like also it's that you know I think
that people criticize us sometimes for
not moving fast enough you know Beverly
Hills is a slow burn but all right I
just you know I worry I don't know I
don't know if Denis we've read a lot
about the stuff that's out there there's
a nice the brandy stuff how much of what
we've seen out there would you say is
truthful or what we're going to see on
the show there are always two sides to
every story and both women will have a
chance to tell their complete thank you
AT&T this is not my computer it seems
like this happened late in the game in
terms of a position would be in the game
the news was brought to us late in the
game so there'll be a lot of season to
watch probably before we get into that
right there's a lot of friendship
there's a lot of fun but you know there
are some quarrels for sure leading up to
it which makes the revelation that much
more like important ok so there's gonna
it's like a snowball effect almost I
think so yes
that's interesting because in seasons
past it's kind of Oren housewives in
general it's almost like a bomb drops
out of nowhere so this is going to be a
slow build yeah it is a slow build it's
a slow build and there are some hints
that are dropped like a I mean looking
back on them I could see why some people
were reacting to some things not because
they knew ahead but it all makes sense
now and that's where I like it all makes
sense now
why it was so like massive Denise there
is a side of you that is hidden
oh she's not who she pretends to be I
don't deserve this
that is a huge thing to be saying what
could be that bad so I think it's safe
to say that Brandis coming with the
receipts okay yeah interesting very
interesting we do see in the trailer for
the season it looks like your email I
get emails all right well let's do it
sorry hold on one second
okay let's keep going Brandis part of
the story is backed up by receipts
it's obviously there's gonna be a lot of
stuff dealt with we see in the trailer
it almost looks like you get heated a
bit with Denise and Aaron it as long as
you feel good about yourselves look in
the mirror when you own it I'm gonna
have to face myself kidding you you know
I've never had any cross words with
Denise I think that she you know and I
still don't and I don't feel a certain
way I'm not really in it
you know um I just think that you know
she's she's gotten herself into a
strange place here you sent a
cease-and-desist
who told you that you're so angry let me
save this I'm gonna go on the record
sending a cease and desist to NBCU
that's like trying to break the house in
Vegas the house always wins
don't be stupid save your money that's a
good advice well she showed called me
and put it builder I tried what I can do
I can't be the legal you know free legal
for everyone right do you really want to
go there come see about me I don't give
up it was surprising to see you at odds
with them because Denise had a pretty
good first season it seems like you guys
everybody's first season like a love
affair and then it all goes to hell what
was your second season
p-panty gay was season your second
season became panty game over my head
that night my husband's like jury I
could not stop staring I mean I would
prefer it if husband's stayed out of the
woman's drama
I really do cuz I think every woman is
smart enough bright enough and
intelligent enough to work out her own
things within the group I think when men
come in you know often times it feels
they feel like they're protecting their
wife when at least in our group and
actually in some ways makes it worse
that's my personal opinion do you think
there's any salvaging her spot in the
group of course we're not I mean I don't
think anybody look this is no one
dislikes Denise we actually had a lot of
fun with Denise last season but this
season it's different so I mean if
everybody in this group has had to
repair and go on I mean you know treat
and I are friends and people are you
know if two people are willing to put
things behind yeah you can go on and
this will be you know in the past it's
really on her if she wants to be a part
of the group or not
let's move off Denise and talk about
some of the other stuff this season we
have a new housewife Garcelle life is an
audition and honey I am getting that
hard
I think ourselves gonna be a really good
housewife she's opinionated she's not
afraid to be herself she's been in the
game a long time and she's got a story
to tell you know just got a story to
tell mother of twins and you know a
working actress and balancing all of
that so she's she's got a good story to
tell and then we have our new friend of
Sutton Hoo in the premiere comes out as
kind of a confessional assassin has some
things to say behind people's backs out
the gate yeah you know good for her I
mean I've actually enjoyed getting to
know Sutton she's a very sweet person
and you know I feel bad about what
happened to her yeah
Yona sucks cuz other sucks it does it
does suck mum but she's she she's gonna
be a great friend of I mean I feel like
we'll see a lot of her because she did
film as full-time and some stuff
happened and the shake out of yeah and
you're gonna meet she doesn't have some
great POVs actually she has some break
one you well we see it right in that
trailer she calls Teddy out for being
boring which was the moment Teddy you
were a little boring are we supposed to
be honest or not who would you say is
the pot stirrer this season up stir
those two my friend Lisa Rinna no
surprise there hey you know what Lisa is
always up front with how she feels
drama aside what are you most excited
for the fans to experience we go to Rome
I mean we go to Rome it's so beautiful
and was so much fun we had a great time
I hope it's not over I love Charlie I
think that listen you've got a group of
women that our friends and hey we had a
conflict and it but it could all be
solved there's nothing that can't be
solved have you had to boil the season
down to one word what's your word for
this season treacherous
is this the most treacherous season yet
when you've been on I think that this
season is the one season that could have
real impact on people's personal lives
do you know what I mean it could be the
one season where it could in really
impact someone's personal life I'm
interested to see how fans react to this
season because having covered it for
years now Beverly Hills has some of the
most vocal people online the way they
talk about the show but it's all been
wrapped up in Vanderpump for as long as
I can remember so I'm interested to see
what the conversation is like now that
she's not a part of the picture and how
the fans react to this mix but I'll tell
you this she wasn't missed during
filming there wasn't a time that we
turned her and looked at each other and
said you know what you know who we're
really missing you know there wasn't
that so
[Music]